levels pit
i'm pumped i'm pumped this is going to
be another great game yeah oh damn it
man
it's hard in europe man to find bad
games like yeah gosh i'm excited let's
go we got that cinematic devils pit and
we're off
all right
okay
yeah okay was definitely knows the
record here but i mean if you're gonna
upset big beyblade right there
great step drops the combo here
and of course walking left is very
important versus foreign i feel like
because you saw him beat the jf assad
just there look at that
look at that you're seeing it and now
we're going to see some homing moves
from chaos
okay it's not over yet oh
okay a lot of defense punished nice yeah
yeah yep uh but as i was saying the
sidewalking left is very important you
saw it beat the jfsr but it also beats
down 3-4 which is a very common um often
starter with horo yeah um so uh you'll
see a lot of that tetsu will just all
like automatically start moving to his
left there just like that they're just
on the off chance that something big is
coming out there and he wants to get
around it yeah
okay oh he was with the lively but who
answers that with a huge upkeep right
there da
yeah
complex claudia without using that
hopkins frames now running two he's got
the wall nice slow parry do you gotta
kill him now with the ragers i think so
i think it might be another mine no oh
what a combo
oh god oh god oh okay
oh
no
okay
oh no
all right
i don't know what to say i don't know
what to say kayla's is definitely
screaming at his monitor right now great
sidestep from him though he is not
phased
i like the usage of four one plus two
i'm not sure but it looks like that's a
move that he's using to track the
sidewalk left yeah it seems to be uh
working that way anyway yeah okay
say sidewalk that beach back one
again yeah with the forward one plus two
oh that was beautiful tetsu's good
attacking you know he's all right
yeah i mean these guys tend to be uh
quite good here uh in eu west man i hope
i hope all the other regions are
watching man because as soon as offline
comes back we're sending our boys down
your side like you know yeah
all right
he does get around on the board there
with a down three four in the end good
stuff there keeping it close
a lot of wonder woman's punish that
but wait a minute
big damage here now
oh he waits for him oh that was so
clever from cairo's
oh no what
that's dead
wow
now that is something that you don't see
k was let through a lot did he started
off the beyblade with the sparkle fist
and finished it the first hit was
blocked and the second hit went through
and maybe chaos was expecting him to
just be testing with the one
hmm
yeah i think that yet again in this
situation very very high pressure
situations and uh maybe you got a little
bit of jittery and you press the button
i'm not sure what it was maybe try to
sidestep or i don't know um but either
way texas taking that and it was very
clever from k was actually at the end he
went for down three four and if you duck
that string
it's very hard to get a guaranteed punch
because the flappies from the stance can
counter hit you if you try to launch it
so to stay ducking but kayla's went for
the mid option instead so like the mind
games are very deep between these two
you can clearly see that tetsu knows
horunk very very well um so kaiwis is
going to have to make um either a
character switch or he's going to have
to just adapt here because the movement
has been on point you saw the sidewalk
and everything i know kevis has a very
strong lydia it's a first of three does
he switch now we'll have to wait and see
i think right now is where you want to
switch and because you have the time if
you lose the next one um you can always
switch back to your main and just pull
it out and stuff but no okay wait it
goes for the infinite pick here infinite
disorder two
yeah which uh i do like this let's have
a look at that panorama here um as we
get into it um very very pretty stage
look at that milky way you've got the
moon and stuff
when's the indefinite is your three i
think yeah i don't think anyone will get
tired you get into infinite is all four
or five you know every single cross
heroes is feeling themselves oh
unfortunately feeling yourself doesn't
make those combos land
go on titsu go on can you make the
comeback
it's gonna be harder i know k was gone
for the infinite stage because of walls
claudia has such a very strong wall game
yeah okay we just want to play pure
second here
okay
nice here we go okay
he's doing a lot of lows working on
those shins man
oh
good step no real punish
i'm loving the move of heaven kay was
nine oh yes
big don't worry two a move that you
don't see a lot of herrings using um but
uh coming up clutch there yeah horizon
has some pretty good punches too man you
know the jabs you see that yeah
nice here we go the vortex gets started
this is going to be a lot of damage yeah
choosing to keep him very very close
here doesn't want him to get away and
adjust
frames skyrocket it's almost a chaos
calling parrot and ends it with the
cinematic perfect man
we've got the koat cinematic universe
going on here right now that's two quick
rounds off okay whis man playing very
solid switching it up
good
now
yep okay
jabbing forward
oh look at that
it does beat the sidewalk left okay it
was adapting here now that's it really
really nice to see
yeah
wow
wow
straight
chaos was mad dude okay
it was just kind of woke up a little bit
here he's getting mad he did and um you
see that right the forward one plus two
the mid the mid punches right the gut
punches the the homing movement down
forward four the backlash you know he's
using these adapting now noticing that
tattoo is just blindly sidewalking left
it worked in the first game but not in
the second game and now it is on tatsu
to make the um the adaptation don't be
too obvious with yours with your um
sidewalk because the thing is that k k
was a very analytical player he
understands how does my opponent react
versus my strings how does he react in
the neutral as well is he sidewalking a
lot you know or what what move choices
does he use chaos is very analytical and
you can see there that was an obvious
answer back to the first match right
very very uh good supporters yeah i mean
that's why it's so dangerous at this
point in the tournament to play chaos on
the long set
just gives him more opportunities
to learn exactly the way you like to
play and here we go one one on the score
account remember guys it is a first to
three not a best of three right now so
tetsu does have another game to play
with here and we're going he's getting
that home turf advantage on the duomo
i like that i like the accent man
yeah just in case people make a make the
mistake you know of the irish and the
italian flag
you know what bring up the italian
accent you get me
[Laughter]
let's
yeah
okay
yeah the back three three uh a new move
there from uh from claudio in terms of
tekken 7 live spam but a really really
good counter at launcher
yeah
oh
counter hits here we go
got that back turn the disrespect
oh yes okay with four rounds in a row
now here looking solid
yeah i mean
he learned something that we didn't here
yep
okay
check him with the back threes okay that
put that [ __ ] that's
better for one plus two so maybe it has
better tracking but just doesn't track
fully yeah absolutely okay here we go
tattoo oh drops it
don't leave that man alive that's
kayla's that's chaos in front of you
okay nine step into the downfall of your
stuff tattoo ending that momentum there
that was four rounds straight from from
cable so one matchup piece one round a
piece exactly what we wanted here for
this winners finals a close up
okay splat there yep damage that's that
claudio already tech right there
and i stepped there from kostol oh
[Music]
chasing each other around the ring here
watch tattoos rage though here it is
chooses to do nothing the beyblade does
not work this time
instant throw break then lovely loses
the homing move and jabs finish it off
kos look is super good in his offense
yep absolutely that's how we saw kos
take the last game just a quick jab
right into the face but a great block
there from tatsu tattoo does have the
sparkle fist as well so if he gets the
wall no not just yet but he does have
all of the other moves armor into the
wall splash are we going to see
something special here
okay
okay here we go okay with us now he's
working on a life deficit but can he
bring it back nice sidewalk again from
tetsu running two's gonna finish here
ladies and gents final round such an
important round who is gonna take the
lead in the set winners finals
okay
nice step
movement is playing such a huge factor
here in this game just watch the way
they move not backwards and forwards but
like side to side always oh wow
it's that one out there okay this
okay it stays dark and clever good
patience there from tattoo
big width
good break oh my god tetsu on point yeah
he's got this there's the blues
wow get those floppy kicks as we were
talking about doors very very difficult
to deal with here and a great tool in
chaos's arsenal here but that was a
super close match spag i don't know man
i mean tattoo can definitely bring it
back and we can see a final game here in
winners final i think we know i think we
could definitely see a final game uh
it's funny because that um that down
back four low is a great a round ender
because if you block it and you try to
even go for a while standing four um the
flappy kicks is going to counter hit you
and that's exactly what happened there
you know you normally think right i
blocked a low is i can punish most lows
are punishable right um but not that one
not if you try to go for 174 you will
get counter hit by the by the by the
highest so yeah again clutch stuff there
test to kind of faltering a little bit
at the end but it's very close like you
said sam right so so close you still
can't call it i know chaos is definitely
in the favorable spot here now going
into the next game with the momentum and
only has to win one more game but tatsu
can definitely spin this match on its
head
you don't want to go into loser back
again man i mean you've got black azam
and super akuma waiting for you there
man
to be this is very important chaos if he
can get this he moves into grand finals
on the winner's side and that's
definitely where you want to be but
we're going back to the series
oh sorry tattoo picked that js sorry i
forgot that he lost the last two i was
like did karis just pick his stage
but no here we go we didn't see a
balcony break actually in the last uh in
the last game so let's see if that's
gonna um come into play here potential
for big damage here at the end of a
combo we've got the explorer claudio as
well that custom man damn we've got book
in the chat saying that i'm putting all
my points on tetsu you've got the belief
right let's go look at the sidewalk and
the side throw i've never seen that
before
technically oh no it's not airborne i
don't think he wouldn't be doing that
much damage doesn't get the wall though
unfortunately no punish on the mid oh
again no confirmed with the downfall
three tetsu usually so good at doing
that rage available for k whis plus
frames oh
one more oh wow okay
and he is not happy to have gone down on
the home turf man i you see the these
are the mind games there right in that
situation the low was so obvious but
because it was obvious it wasn't obvious
yeah i mean like
he's not gonna do that that's too
obvious he did it
hey around those down four twos
okay
played laden
running twos running twos
oh my god this is so oh thank you this
could be dead that's it right
if you didn't drop it run it yes
oh my god
try to comment back here against all of
the odds here hey whis sitting pretty
buck is sitting right in the chat
man running twos grabs broken you said
it yourself there samuel are we going to
see the balcony break and it came in
clutch there for tetsu absolutely the
classic rolling choke
oh it doesn't work anymore man
yeah he's expecting him to stay down but
it peels him off the wall here what are
we going to see for opie
could have got more with the 4-2-2 it's
okay though tay was now at the wall has
pressure
nice
okay
stillwood is back to the wall though
tattoo really has to watch himself watch
the rage now wow
you see once again you blocked the down
three four you stayed ducking because
you thought the high was coming the cave
is one step ahead once again it goes for
the mid
yeah
oh he's so lucky he's so lucky that was
about to hurt him so bad because he eats
a bit okay with his leg
okay
okay was half health yeah he has a
massive life he'd have to but kevin can
still make the comeback all he needs is
to string together some strings here
one h that's her
i thought that the walk was coming in
here lateral movement from both players
stare down
30 seconds
you went for the rage out there i think
i think so
streams oh make some time you're going
for the big
manages to make the comeback get here
we've got a set point to move into grand
finals testing at the back foot
yep he definitely needs to pull
something special out right now this is
winners final we're talking about ladies
and gentlemen
two two okay was behind but we've seen
him make the comeback before big screw
yeah i think he hit him at the hopkick
there dropped the combo though okay was
on the back foot once again tetsu has a
small life feed but it's a very fragile
one running two plus frames
running two again he loves that move man
oh oh no was black okay what's the save
for a minute
we'll stop 50 50 time goes for the mid
oh
nice oh my god tattoo comes back ladies
and gentlemen you can't call this you
cannot call this this is the tightest
game that we've seen all day today man
2-2 winners final
who is gonna take this it all comes down
to this final match is it gonna be uk or
is it gonna be germany i wanna see you
guys in the chat man who do you think is
gonna take you man get loud for your
boys here we go this is gonna be great
and i believe that caves will be
probably going back to the infinite
stage right because that's where he
managed to make the comeback and get the
match win um the walls will probably be
out of play here but stick with horung i
believe no lydia played here from k was
no no um i mean he definitely goes
through phases of liking lydia and but
uh i like this that he's just sticking
he's sticking to his guns you know he
wants that stage pick give him a little
bit more advantage over tetsu right now
who is in like such a good spot right
now like just winning the last game just
needs three more rounds to move forward
into the grand final that's where the
money that's where the points that's
where the pride starts mounting up even
if you lose it at the grand final you
say well i'm a grand finalist like
um whereas a winner's finalist
whatever man
but here we go
ladies and gentlemen final game between
these two well potentially final game
the loser can come back through the
losers bracket yeah we see the infinite
okay which is sticking to the to the big
kicker himself
um
this is going to be fun this is gonna be
a great man let's see what happens here
we've seen the mind games play out
throughout these four matches but it all
comes down to this we're going to the
infinite azure two one of the most
beautiful stages in tekken to finish a
beautiful set here who is going to make
it to grand finals here with west europe
masters let's go
nice block
really really good one of the few
launchers that we've seen here um just
coming from neutral a lot of the time
it's uh mix-ups or counter-hits or
whatever that was just a straight raw
aren't you yeah
man getting them health sweeps in there
nice
okay okay which is not uh committing to
his low blocks here
and getting poked out just a little bit
there with tattoos blows boom
wow that's gotta hurt blue sparkles man
chaos always has that just friend
skyrocker rocket locked and loaded
absolutely here beautiful k whisk good
and punished we're starting to challenge
these lows now what's that's gonna do
what is tetsu gonna do here
um it seems like he's making great
headway with those lows but uh look at
hey whis now here's the washing machine
man the washing machine of feet you got
it just kicking them but wait a minute
the big launch the cross-up good
patience to stay down
will you stop
opt for the low
oh the tongue he knows it he knows that
string looking for big damage here no
keeping him close
nice the wagon
no
way did he get around that that was so
clever how do you read that potential
final round now for kos that wasn't even
a foil around man crazy stuff the
heavyweight champions now one round away
can't test him at the reverse sweeping
nice blocking the hell sleep there
oh i'm feeling a final final round right
now uh
imagine
a great start though and we've seen that
camus knows tattoo's not blocking low at
all just been going for the the raw low
mid mix ups yeah
okay
he does have sparkle fists though oh
but he almost straight through this is
going to be huge damage
and there it is oh
my heart was like fluttering like a
butterfly right there oh my god i
thought that was where chaos was about
to lose
whoo
yep
amazing amazing come back there from
from kwis you know after losing i
believe he lost the first match was
looking very very shaky for him but he
managed to beat his nemesis this is
someone that has beaten him in so many
tournaments but it's 3-2 in favor of
cables taking it no round brown at the
end and he moves into grand fine